Where are we, Joshua?
We're in Hannah Hall's houseboat
in Sausalito, California.
San Francisco is a bit of our
happy place, right?
- It is.
We love it up there.
People keep asking me now
if I could live on a houseboat.
- No.
- I couldn't either!
No, no, I don't think you could.
Oh, I couldn't. Yeah.
When writing this book,
I had a draft that looked
very unlike the story
we now know today.
And I remember, you
came into the room
and you said,
“What if you think about it
a little bit differently?”
When you said that, it helped me
imagine a different...
- Ending.
- Which is a prime example
sort of, of how our writing life
works at home.
We read everything
the other writes.
If I had my way, we
would sit in the
same office all day.
- We do a lot.
You try to go to
your secret office.
It’s supposed to be secret
from our son, who found it.
He loves it, loves it. Yeah.
Good day at work?
Better now that it's over.
It felt very natural for us to
start writing the show together.
And you love being on set.
I continue to learn
so much from you.
I'm used to adapting
historical pieces.
- This is quite a departure for you.
- It's quite a departure.
Roll sound!
Adapting a historical
event is hard
‘cause there's a ton of
research, whereas here
we had this great book,
and that was the huge help.
What I love about
your writing is,
it's so insightful and thoughtful.
And so, all those episodes
you took the first pass on
and then I just cleaned up
around the margins.
You can do all sorts of things
in screenwriting
that I could never do though.
Making this world visual and..
- Dual dialogue. Using Final Draft.
- All the things.
In some ways
it felt like I was going to
film school working with you.
There’s gonna come a time
when I won't be able to
keep her safe anymore.
Not from anything.
One of the things I’ve always loved
about the book, is that it is
both this suspense-mystery,
but it is also a meditation
on parenting and found families.
Do you think you could
have written that
before we had Jacob?
- I don't know.
This book is a love
letter to Jacob.
I always tell him it's
his book, which
he thinks the whole
book’s about him.
But in some ways it is.
You are absolutely going to be
what's best for her.
And you know, me.
It's been very nice to walk down
memory lane with you today.
I've adapted a bunch of books,
but I’ve never gotten to adapt
a book written by my wife Laura,
which has been a joy.
And I only hope I
have done it justice.
You did.
There's not a whole lot
you could tell me about
that would change
anything between us.
Well, thank God for that.